wir schauen wir auf unseren geldbeutel
da sieht es nämlich schlechter aus drin
der teuer schock der ist schon längst da
und jetzt erwischt es die ersten mieter
eiskalt waren duschen weil man mag geht
jetzt nicht mehr ja das ist der schock
für mieter von 600 wohnungen der
wohnungsgenossenschaft dippoldiswalde
dort gibt es ein aushang schauen wir mal
rein und neben der haustür informieren
sie die mieter das warmwasser jetzt
nutze bestimmten uhrzeit und zwar
morgens um vier bis acht mittags von 11
bis 13 uhr und abends von 17 bis 21 uhr
fließt ja wirklich irre es geht nicht
darum die mieter zu ärgern sondern sich
auf das einzustellen was wir im nächsten
jahr vielleicht sonst nicht mehr
bezahlen können so sagt es
genossenschaftsvorstand frank kühn
meißgeier ja es gehe lediglich um einen
beitrag sich ein wenig einzuschränken
wir wollen dass mieter gut durch diese
krise kommen das leben ist schon so
teuer genug sagt er er seit monaten
leider ganz deutschland unter den
explodierenden preisen und gestern nun
erklärt kanzler olaf scholz sind teuer
schock zur chefsache endlich zitierte
spitzenvertreter aus wirtschaft
wissenschaft und gewerkschaften ins
kanzleramt noch herauskam nichts gar
nichts die krisengipfels krachend
gescheitert statt einer konzentrierten
aktion gegen den teuer schock wie schaut
sie versprochen hatte ganz am ende nur
floskeln und durchhalteparolen so wie
diese hier wir müssen uns darauf
einstellen dass diese lage auf absehbare
zeit sich nicht ändern wird wir schauen
raus in rein in die pressekonferenz von
oder scholz
wir werden das land durch diese krise
nur gut durchkommen wenn wir uns
unterhaken wenn wir gemeinsam und auf
lösung einigen vieles davon wird in
diesen tagen wirksam dazu gehört zb die
anhebung des grundfreibetrags bei der
steuer die arbeitnehmerpauschale
200 euro einmalzahlung für die
grundsicherung der hörer
heizkostenzuschuss für grund für
wohngeldempfänger 100 euro pro kind
gezahlt werden 20 euro jeden monat für
kinder in ärmeren verhältnissen
300 euro energie geld es geht insgesamt
um etwa 20 milliarden euro die heute auf
den stromrechnungen insgesamt lasse
tasten und das er bis das eine
entlastung für viele für familien für
unternehmen und das ist richtig so und
wir begrüssen jetzt hier bei uns im
studio gitta connemann chefin der
wirtschafts und mittelstands union hier
bei uns im studio frau connemann sie
verstehen sowohl die belange der
arbeitgeber als auch der arbeitnehmer
wie müssen sich die löhne denn
entwickeln um der inflations krise zu
begegnen entscheidend ist dass am ende
mehr im geldbeutel bleibt denn die beste
lohnsteigerung bringt nichts wenn der
staat sie weg besteuert und das ist
zurzeit der fall der staat ist ein
großer inflations gewinner und deshalb
müssen wir runter mit der
einkommensteuer davon haben die
arbeitnehmer ebenso etwas wie übrigens
auch betriebe und unter anderem rentner
jetzt haben wir hier in der sendung eine
wie wir finden jetzt ihren vorschlag
gesehen vermieter die einfach durch
zeiten angeben damit man dort weniger
wasser irgendwann auch weniger energie
das geht dann auch ins heizen verbraucht
was halten sie von dieser maßnahme das
zeigt die hilflosigkeit die aktuell da
ist denn es fehlt ja sowohl den bürgern
die auch den betrieben eine perspektive
und eine planungssicherheit und deshalb
hätte ich mir auch gewünscht dass es
gestern keine konzertierte aktion mit
einigen wenigen gibt sondern einen
echten inflations gipfel wo alle
beteiligten an einen tisch kommen denn
die inflation trifft alle und jeder ist
zwar auch gefordert aber die
bundesregierung der kanzler muss sagen
wohin ist eigentlich geht und die
menschen und betriebe brauchen
sicherheit wenn sie dort mit am tisch
gesessen hätten was hätten sie den
kanzler geraten was wären ihre
lösungsvorschläge vielleicht für diese
inflations krise gewesen zunächst einmal
brauchen betriebe und bürger entlastung
und zwar nicht mit strohfeuer wie mal
einen neuen europe nv ticket oder einer
energie preisgeld pauschale die bei
vielen nicht ankommt wie zum beispiel
rentnern und studierenden die aber auch
hohe kosten haben sondern strukturelle
entlastung das heißt
einkommensteuertarife anpassen damit
mehr im geldbeutel bleibt aber auch die
stromsteuer runter denn wir brauchen
billigen bezahlbaren strom 2 tatsächlich
sehen dass der staat sich überprüft wir
können nicht weitermachen wie bisher das
heißt ein aufwuchs anstellen stoppen
subventionen angucken beraterverträge
mal kündigen damit eine solide
finanzierung gegeben ist und das dritte
ist natürlich auch die energie frage zu
beantworten denn am ende führt die
aktuelle energie und sicherheit zu
inflation und das heißt die ampel muss
sagen bin ich inzwischen offen für alle
optionen wir brauchen jede
kilowattstunde
und sie muss sich auch verhalten zu
fragen wie dem weiterbetrieb von
kernkraftwerken ganz ganz großes thema
auch haben wir hier auch sehr oft in der
sendung gitta connemann vielen
herzlichen dank für ihre analyse zu
diesem thema es wird ein bisschen angst
und bange wenn man in diesem herbst und
winter schaut muss ich leider zu geben
danke für ihren besuch im studio vielen
dank